the dark side of the force
guys i finally watched the star war
movie
[Music]
i suspect that a terrible secret has
been kept on this planet
that sand people exist in far greater
numbers
i'm just joking i know that lion's not
in the actual dune book david lynch put
that line in the movie whatever i'm just
kidding i'm i kid i kill a kid
so guys this is an exciting day because
today
i'm going to review star wars a new hope
which is the first movie in the first
star wars trilogy
but it's actually episode number four
because the other ones were made
afterwards which is really
annoying and weird and i don't
understand it but that's not the point
but anyway everyone knows what star wars
is
it's a beloved series i'd seen bits and
pieces of star wars i
it was never really my thing i never
really got into it i never really
got the hype or knew what it was all
about i saw the force awakens when it
came out i really don't even remember
what happened in it i saw the last jedi
when it came out
thought it was kind of good i don't
really remember what happened in it
here's the thing i'm a science fiction
book fan i
read science fiction books and that is
my primary
method of consumption of sci-fi i do
like sci-fi movies as well but i
tend to go for more serious sci-fi
movies i i like things like
hitchhiker's guide to the galaxy because
that's awesome but you know star wars
was just never my thing i always
thought it was i always thought it was
you know kind of corny kind of basic it
wasn't gritty enough for me and
it did lots of reasons but i never
really just was able to get into it but
so many of you
for so long have wanted to hear my
opinions on the star wars movies
the original trilogy especially as a
dune fan i am aware of the fact that
george lucas took
a lot of influence from frank herbert's
dune when it came to the creation of
star wars
and i did see some of that watching the
movie and we'll get into that so where
do i start
star wars a new hope i guess i can just
describe the setting of star wars to you
as if you don't know what it is
so from a dune fans perspective from the
perspective of someone that's never seen
star wars this is what star wars is
about
so you got like the empire right and
they're the bad guys
and they want to
hurt the good guys who are
anybody that they don't like
and then there's also these people
called the jedi
who are not around anymore because darth
vader killed all of them
and and but there's one more and he's
like hiding off on
arrakis no excuse me tatooine
a planet with not two moons but two sons
all right and back up there's there's
this kid named luke
on tatooine and and he doesn't want to
be on tatooine
but he can't leave because he has an
aunt and uncle and then and then
they die and then he can leave and
obi-wan kenobi is all like
he's the jedi guy and he's all like
let's go
um let's go fight the empire and learn
jedi magic stuff
and the jedi are kind of like the bini
jesuit except
not really like the benny jesuit
they could do like the voice but it's
not really the voice
anyway they go to this cantina with all
these weird aliens
and they chop one of the aliens hands
off because they want to kill luke for
no reason
and then they meet this guy han solo and
there's this big
woogie thing that just goes it's it's a
wookie
big and hairy and he's in these guys are
cool
and then there's this this weird scene
with this big slug thing
and it was like obviously added cgi here
there's like
an original version that i should watch
but i saw the cgi version so there's
this
slug thing called jabla hut and he's
like a bounty hunter and he's after this
guy han solo
but he's like so he's like sending
people after han solo to like kill him
or whatever
but then he lets han go when he's like
okay yeah you
i got a better bounty i can give you
your money or something i
i don't know but anyways they all get on
the flat flying saucer ship the
millennium falcon and they're locked
they're like we gotta we gotta go
and then and then the stormtrooper guys
attack and they're all like
you we gotta we gotta attack uh but
anyway
rewind rewind rewind so there's this
there's this lady named princess leia
right and so in the beginning of it
she's on the ship right and there's
these two droids
c3po and r2d2 and they're all like oh no
we got it we gotta like we're being
attacked
and you know she puts this message in
and and the little droid r2d2 and she's
like it got a message for obi-wan kenobi
and she's like help me open kenobi
and then darth vader gets there and he's
all like dun dun
it's all crazy and stuff and then like
so okay darth vader gets there and he's
all like where are the jaguar
where is it where is the droid because
the droids have like some kind of plans
it did plans to destroy this big thing
called the death star which can like
destroy planets and stuff because the
the empire just wants to destroy planets
because they just destroy planets
and so they even they even destroy like
princess leia's planet but anyways
everyone dicks around for a little bit
flies through space do like weird sci-fi
goofy just for a little bit and then
they they go and save princess leia
and then everything's cool but then but
then obi-wan kenobi has to face off with
darth vader
and then there he's either like all
fighting and he's all like if you strike
me down i should become
more powerful than you could ever
imagine and then here was it was
actually pretty cool because he just
like kind of gets like sliced with the
light saber sword thing that like how do
those work like the
the like laser thing just like kind of
like i don't i don't i don't get the
laser
knife thing that like stops in the air i
don't understand how it works
but anyway he slices him with the sword
thing and he just kind of becomes
nothing and then for the rest of the
movie he's just like this ghostly form
also i have to add that this movie
is like following every beat of the
hero's journey like
seriously it's like at the death of the
mentor like the denial of
of the pathway looks like i don't want
to go
then like his family dies and then he
goes so something takes him away from
him and he's on his destiny and it's
like
all of it's there but anyways there's
obi-wan kenobi dies
and then he's just like a mystical voice
and he's all like luke used the force
and and yeah but anyway basically
they got the they got the they got the
plans for this flaw
and this big this big star destroyer
thing so they gotta
they gotta destroy it by means of this
ridiculously
complicated method that involves like
going through all these like little core
doors in it and like
getting it right in the right place so
like anyway they're all doing it and
they're flying the space ships like
space battles don't do anything for me
really so they're all
they're all flying the ships and then
like luke uses the force and he gets it
and then they blow up the big death star
and the empire is all like no
[Music]
um and then that's star war
a new hope i know it's star wars it's a
joke
it's a joke what can i say about
this movie
it was it was it was
i it was okay it was okay
yeah it was okay i respect that it came
out in the 70s and it's got all these
like
cool practical effects and all of these
puppets and models that really hold up
and it's like this
sprawling epic space adventure it's like
this was never
really done before but all in all i feel
like the movie itself
is kind of simple
and a little bit dare i say
boring i wasn't as
entertained by this movie as i expected
to be
like i said for me a lot of times with
like the space battles and like the
the adventure scenes running down corner
corridors and
pew pew pew with the blasters and laser
gun weapon things that doesn't really do
it for me and that's a lot of this it's
a lot of just like
stuff like that like like like fighting
the storm troopers and
bop bop with my gun and pew pew pew down
the corridor or whatever
and i i just i just that's not that's
for me that's not what does it
so while i do respect this film
a new hope for being what it was and you
know just kicking off sci-fi in a new
way and just making people understand
that sci-fi can be done
you know and can be brought to the
mainstream i respected for that
but as far as like me enjoying the movie
as a film i can't say i really enjoy it
that much
but it'll be interesting to go through
all of the star wars material
and you know review it
and you know put my opinions out there
because i will admit it's kind of crappy
that i like read off this sci-fi i know
about all this sci-fi but i've never
really seen all the star wars stuff
i'm trying to fill the gaps in my
knowledge
and you know allow star wars allow star
wars into my little dimension here now
am i gonna become a huge star wars fan
i don't know maybe we'll have to see how
my experience with the rest of the
movies go
okay so my favorite parts of the movie i
love the droids
c3po and r2d2 they're like so awesome
and so funny and so goofy
i love both of them i love darth vader
just
choking people just choking people to
death like
on screen it's really really cool and
then like i said all of the practical
effects
and all the models there was a lot of
cgi
editing done over top of what looked
like
was the older movie so that was a little
weird and i
don't know where i could find a version
of the original movie
if i can someone let me know and i might
if it's different enough i might have to
like review it separately because i hear
that maybe it is
differently i'm not sure but anyway for
star wars
episode 4 a new hope
i really really don't like that title i
give this movie
in context being the first thing of its
kind
5.7 out of 10. that's that's where i
have to go with a new hope
i enjoyed it but you know not really
it's not
something that i would like just be like
oh put on star wars a new hope but
anyway like i said i will be reviewing
the other two movies
in this trilogy as well as
the prequel films which apparently like
everyone hates for some reason
well i'm gonna be reviewing these and
it's gonna be fun so that's my review of
star wars a new hope
it's probably the most jumbled review
i've ever done on this channel but
thank you guys for sitting through it
and make sure you like and subscribe
for more quinn's ideas peace out hey
guys if you want to support this channel
check me out
on patreon you can also click the paypal
link in the description to make a
one-time donation
star wars
star wars star star wars screw star wars
and star trek you know looking at
my good star trek you know i'm saying
yeah yeah [ __ ]
freaking enterprise that's right wharf
yeah wharf knows what's up
yeah yeah data2 yeah we know what's up
this is my crew
yeah it's my crew these are my guys you
got deanna and rick up there you can't
even see that but yeah that's my crew
i'm so stupid yeah i'm not here